)
- Pour les conservateursc'c'c'ce
qui se trnrne.
La fin de la tumultueuse ère
Jason Kenney, marquée par la
pandémie et les déchirements
internes sur les restrictions
sanitaires.
urur le parti conservateur uni,
l'heure est maintenant
le prochain chef et prochainpre?
Progressistes, centristes ou
populistes, urbains ou ruraux.
le spectre conservateur qui est
représenté dans la course.
(rires)
Une course dominée non pas
par des enjeux classiques
comme l'économie, la santé
ou l'éducation.
Mais plutôt par le sort
de la province dans le pays.
Et c'est la favorite présuméeden
à ce chapitre.
Avec sa loi sur  s souveraineté,
Danielle Smith propose une
Si elle l'emporte, plus question
de faire appliquer en Alberta
en matière d'environnement,
qui seraient considérées
comme contraires aux intérêinin.
Une idée radicale, dénoncée
par des constitutionnalistes
et les autres candidats,
la base militante du parti.
Création d'un fonds de pension
albertain, ou d'une nouvelle
police provinciale,
constitutionnelles ; les deux
autres favoris de cette course
Brian Jean, ancien chef du
WIldrose, et Travis Toews,
jouent eux-aussi la carte
de l'autonomie.Et veulent que le
davantage l'approche québécoise
du fédéralisme.
Si le sujet est omniprésent
dans la course, c'est surtout
que la règle d'un membre,
de poids aux militants.
Des membres qui se trouvent
majoritairement en milieu rural,
en affaires publiques.
GRAHAM GEREIN, consultant,
New West Publics Affairs
- La ruralité  u u u u u u u u a
du parti ces jours-ci,
particulièrement sur les
questions d'autonomie
et d'ind
du Canada.
- Inflation, santé ou éducation,
les préoccupations des
Albertains moyens ne sont
des autres Canadiens.
La distorsion entre ce que veut
la base du Parti conservateur
uni et la population générale
croit cette sondeuse.
Cette course à la succession
de Jason Kenney doit en principe
mettre fin aux damamamamamamama.
Mais les débats entourant la loi
sur la souveraineté ont été
à ce point acrimonieux,
qu'il esque Danielle Smith fera
l'unanimité si elle gagne.
- Elle aurait besoin
d'enentifier les enjeux qui vont
au-delà de sa base, pour parler
à une plus grande audienceaiaia.
- La dernière année a été des
plus tumultueuse pour
albertain. Et rien n'indique
que les prochains mois seront
successeure de Jason Kenne